how president Biden has been a
friend for 40 years.
I obviously, you've not always
seen eye to eye on a lot of
issues.
He says that he wants signed a
photo for you.
I don't agree with a darn thing
you say, but I love you.
How do you describe your
relationship when it comes to
nobody is there, just you two
on the phone?
He's telling you what you need
from each other.
>> That's exactly what happens.
We have been around the block
so many times, we were the new
kids on the block when he came
in as a young senator from
Delaware, and I came in as the
young Israeli diplomat in the
embassy.
This was in 1982.
We have known each other for a
long time, 40 years.
We speak openly to one another.
I think the president Biden's
commitment to Israel's real,
it's not just words, it comes
from the heart.
My commitment aligns with the
United States Israel.
It has gone through many
presidents, and it has to be
bipartisan.
I believe that.
It doesn't mean that we don't
--
it doesn't mean that we agree
on everything.
We disagreed on many things.
We've disagreed on Iran, we
disagreed on other things, and
we have agreed on many things.
We've agreed that aligns has to
be unshakable, because when you
look at the Middle East, and
you look at this part of the
world, and you say, well, where
do you have a bastion of common
interests and common values?
It is Israel.
Most Americans understand that.
Our interests or sound, Israel
remains diplomatic, it will be
democratic after these
democratic reforms, and be more
democratic.
>> It's not democratic in the
west bank though, that is the
argument.
>> I don't say that we don't
have right now military needs,
but I'm saying that we can
fashion them in a civilian
agreement that maintains Israel
overriding security.
I don't think the Palestinians
are there.
What I will say is that our
interests are converging.
As never before, because in the
21st century, the future
belongs to --
Israel's the innovation nation.
The other innovation nation, I
think the U.S. Is the big one,
U.S. --
Israel is the second one.
We provide valuable Intel,
invaluable cybersecurity,
weapons development, and
civilian technology that is
changing the world.
That is why our Arab neighbors
came to the Abraham accords.
Both for security, but also for
civilian technology which
benders the lives of their
people.
>> One thing I want to ask you
about Russia and Ukraine is an
adviser to zelenskyy flooded
your name as somebody who might
be a decent mediator between
zelenskyy and Putin, between
Putin and Russia.
I am wondering if anybody in a
position of power has ever
floated that idea to you, and
what would be your willingness
to take on that job?
>> I was asked to do that early
on in the breakout of the
Ukraine war.
I was an opposition leader at
the time, and I said I have a
rule.
One prime minister at a time.
One president at a time.
>> Who asked you to do it?
>> I was asked.
I don't know if it was official,
or if it was an official, and
so I didn't even pursue it.
I said there is a prime
minister, let him decide what
to do.
He tried, did not succeed.
If --
>> We do you do it now?
>> If I'm asked by both sides,
and frankly if I'm asked by the
United States, because I think
that you cannot have too many
cooks in the kitchen, and I am
--
we have our own backyard to
deal with.
It is not that I don't think
this is important, it's a
monumental importance because
of the piece of the world.
As I think that the piece of
the world's ex, stake getting
nuclear weapons, it will be
destabilizing the entire world.
And so I think that really
devoting my efforts to that,
the piece ideas that I have,
economic ideas, but if asked by
all relevant parties, I will
certainly consider it.
I'm not pushing myself, which
is --
I have been around long enough
to know that there needs to be
a ripe time.
The ripe circumstances.
If they arrive, I will
certainly consider it.
>> Trump has already launched a
2024 presidential bid.
You've said a few things about
what he did for Israel while he
was president.
You've also criticized him for
the insurrection that he
incited, which you called quote,
a disgraceful act that must be
vigorously condemned.
And his recent, rather shocking
willingness to sit down and
break bread with holocaust
deniers and virulent
antisemites.
Nick Fuentes and Kanye west,
for example.
Do you have any concerns if he
is back in the white house, do
you think it's time for the
Republican party to look for a
new generation of leadership?
>> First of all, I did praise
president trump, because he did
great things for Israel.
He recognized Jerusalem as our
capital, kind of late because
3000 years ago, king David
proclaimed it is such.
He moved the American embassy
there, he recognized our
sovereignty, leading out of the
dangerous nuclear deal with
Iran, he helped the peace
accords with the Arab states.
He's done great things.
I think that he made a big
mistake with this Kanye west
thing, and I said so.
I'm not going to intervene in
new politics, you know that.
You tried, it's good, you try